- So you, you had some health issues,
but you're doing well, right?
- I did.
Right about this time, last year.
- Yeah, literally.
- I was in the hospital.
I went in for one thing, ended
up having surgery for five.
So it was buy one, get four free.
- [Kelly] Oh my...
That's scary.
- No, it was really a
very scary time, Kelly.
It was a very scary time
and Al is one who likes to
look forward, not backward.
- Oh, the optimist.
- Which is great,
ever the optimist.
But it was a very, very difficult time
and we are so blessed to have him
in full form and just great.
(audience applauding)
- But I have to say
too, your granddaughter,
she kind of played a role, right?
- Yes, yeah.
I found out while I was in the
hospital that my oldest girl,
Courtney, was expecting
our first grandchild.
- Aw!
- And there she is.
Little Sky.
- Look!
- Oh, you can all go, "Aw!"
- I know.
So special.
- But I think more than anything else,
I think just knowing
that she was coming along
over this last year.
- Exactly.
- Because it's been a progression,
but you've just gotten
stronger and stronger
and so here he is.
So now when he drops his underwear
and his stuff on the floor or whatever
and I wanna get upset with him,
I'm just like, you know?
- They're there.
- I could have been dead.
- Oh my God, he's gonna use it.
That's gonna be his card.
- He's like, "This is
what you prayed for!"
- It's your fault.
You saved me, sorry!
- You didn't want me to go anywhere.